and here we are together with Maxim R
graph we're absolutely shocked with with
news Sam just lost the game I mean it's
unbelievable Maxim but back to you you
won such a great game today um and after
so many draws finally you managed to to
score I remember this not I mean not
shaky game against yanomi but now let's
go to the game which you won against
Wesley so yes uh again I definitely
missed an opportunity so what level was
minus one so that's probably why he went
for this very sharp line and that was
like uh Vladimir played it Kik and
leevon as well so it's very
topical uh I know was that W had a game
in US championship against Mishka I
think Mishka played Knight C6 so Knight
D7 G4 C8 so of course I want to take the
Knight yeah like sometimes you manage to
do so no this is like the topical like
Gary used to say like whenever you can
take on C you you do it you don't
hesitate yes you just you just do it but
was on G5 Knight H5 F4 and at first I
wanted Rook C3 mhm but then I realized I
might have Knight F4 so I did it I
wasn't sure about the positions like
there's many moves for white you can
start with G6 sometimes I don't think
that
works um but even moves like Knight
Bishop D5 I was not sure like Knight D5
e and maybe
H4 I wasn't sure about all these sort of
position there's many ways like maybe
you can play Knight F5 and H4 so but
then I wanted again Rook C3 Rook C3 no
matter what and then he played this
Knight A6 and how did you estimate the
position after those exchanges I thought
Knight D6 was very strange because well
here
I assume they cannot be
worse um I for a while Bishop G5 yes but
I couldn't make it
work I thought maybe there's something
but I couldn't make it
work uh because the problem is Rook C4
you go maybe Rook F1 you threaten always
back rank mates and after Rook C3 BC
maybe some Queen H4 I don't know what's
going on yes but it's no problem yes you
give just same Rook F1
always so I couldn't make it work so I
just took Bishop C3 and Bishop G5 I
thought um I thought here maybe bishop
D5 was
best uh Bishop D7 took me by surprise
cuz uh I mean it was very tempting for
me to play Bishop H4 always to Uncle the
king but then I thought anyway my Bishop
on G5 is so good so let's first provoke
Bishop D2 I thought that you played Rook
C to give the second Rook
now no to play Rook C4 no I'm joking I
me you just said that anytime you have
this chance to give the no it wouldn't
be so bad but um yeah and here Queen F3
I think uh yeah W made bit of inaccuracy
I think he wanted Rook D1 here but he
realized probably that Rook C4 queen f8
king H7 so like Rook F7 would lose
because well you
uh you give one more check you are first
to give the Checkmate yes I mean and if
you go Queen F5 which must have been his
idea I think here D5 is extremely strong
yeah and then push pawns just they they
run yes because so let's say then you
enter the ending right and um yes and at
first I thought I was winning here like
I thought this was very nice e for
Bishop F2 and I don't mind giving uh the
per of Bishops because I mean given my
Bishop because of the Rook on A1 and
King is stuck but actually um after H4 I
think like for instance
here if he goes hook
G1 I couldn't find the
win because after E3 goes Rook
G3 it feels like it's already almost
only one the but he still has this ideas
was check and Rook A7 exactly yeah some
Perpetual so I couldn't find the win and
I was like uh not sure mm but he didn't
play this move yes yeah no in the end I
had found some idea to to keep the game
going
um maybe maybe I think I wanted E2 and
Bishop C4 mhm but even then King
F2 and yes yes because the bishop no but
because the bishop on C4 prevents uh the
mate yes so then you have chance to play
Rook D1 and this mhm okay Bishop C4
looks very strong yeah so when was the
moment you realized that you already
like winning this game um I mean even
here I wasn't
sure like I would need to cheat to no
yeah I'm not surprised it felt it felt
like it's not winning this yeah mhm
because um I mean it could easily be
winning because my H Point runs but but
I really wasn't sure and I wasn't sure
also because probably at some point it
gets like let's say something like
this and this positions I wasn't sure
because my pawns are running and I have
B Pawn so you can never give the Rook
but because it's h and G I assumed it
would be draw because probably you can
just give um all the checks in world
what was the final mistake of Wesley
which helped you to win the game uh I
think Rook G7 I think Rook G7 is bad
because then when my Bishop goes to F5
well have good feeling you and and and
the Machine yeah king1 was probably
still though but okay already very
difficult yeah Maxim I mean what what a
great game how do you feel about the
start do you feel that you didn't get
some points which you had to get or uh
maybe I mean especially the game before
was Yan but at the same very provocative
right um yeah I mean he just blender and
then uh I was to P up I was trying to
make things uh easy for me but um this
night game turned not to be much more
complicated than I thought it would be
uh but there were some games where like
I mean of course against Fabiano I was
first winning but then I was completely
lost and against Anish in the first
round I was absolutely lost uh without a
chance so so in the end one is not bad
is good score I had four blocks already
so I'm going to push my luck tomorrow of
course and we wish you all the best of
luck tomorrow thank you and we're going
back to the studio to you guys thank you
Anastasia and